hi I'm Kristen Goodwin on this episode
of the Fox News rundown the presidential
race is heating up but amid the corona
virus outbreak and its economic fallout
will the president and presumptive
Democratic nominee Joe Biden change
their campaigning strategies Republican
National Committee spokesperson Liz
Harrington and former Obama economic
adviser Robert wolf discussed the 2020
election the possibility of another
stimulus package and the state of the
economy and estates ease kovat 19
restrictions cases of the virus are
still surging in the u.s. dr. amesh
amalga senior scholar at the johns
hopkins university center for health
security
weighs in on how this uptick in
infections could impact the nation's
plans to reopen plus commentary from fox
nation host abby hornacek the fox news
rundown is a Daily News podcast where we
take a deeper look at the stories
important to you you can subscribe on
your favorite podcast player by going to
FoxNews podcast.com Brian Kilmeade
I'm Martha McCallum I'm David Asman and
this is the Fox News rundown
Wednesday June 24th 2020 I'm Dave
Anthony president Trump hit the road
again
campaigning in Arizona as Republicans
keep pushing back on polls showing him
trailing Joe Biden
I see the methodology and all of these
mainstream polls the vast majority are
just wrong and the same thing that you
did in 2016 and Lisa Brady from beaches
to bars the crowds are coming back
across America sometimes leaving masks
and social distancing behind we are
going to see more cases more
hospitalizations and more deaths until
there is a vaccine and we can't behave
as if the virus isn't out there and I'ma
be hornacek I've got the final word on
the fox news rundown
for the second time in four days
president Trump left Washington this
time going to Yuma Arizona my
administration has done more than any
Administration in history to secure our
southern border our border has never
been more secure inspected border wall
under construction now up to 200 miles
illegal immigration is down 84% from
this time last year the president later
went to a church in Phoenix that was
packed full of students who are Trump
supporters the president loves to get
outside the swamp and meet directly with
the American people
Liz Harrington is spokesperson for the
Republican National Committee and says
the wall is an important issue still I
think a lot of liberal media outlets
have stopped talking about this issue
because they can't say that's all is not
going up because we have completed over
200 miles and there will be over 500
miles by the end of 2021 so that's a
major accomplishment the president is
committed to securing the border really
prioritizing American citizens first
which has always been such a such a
central part to rebuilding our country
rebuilding our economy and the promises
president Trump made in 2016 that he
continues to deliver on but the
president has been called when it comes
to his immigration policy when it comes
to what's happened with all the protests
across the country he's been called a
racist by so many people how does he
deal with that and how do you deal with
that to counter those kinds of words
used against him well it's the same
playbook unfortunately Democrats in the
media always call Republicans these
horrible smears when they can't win the
argument and we saw it in 2016 Hillary
Clinton just calling us deplorable and
irredeemable that PlayBook hasn't
changed and President Trump he weathers
it he focused on what's more important
which is uplifting the ideals that we
have in common and it's uplifting the
history of the country that we can learn
from but also adhere to those founding
principles of equality under the law
Equal Opportunity are rights guaranteed
by God not by
government and I think this election is
really going to show that dividing
contract on the one hand you have
Democrats unable to distance themselves
from members of their own party calling
for lawlessness and defunding and
dismantling of the police not taking a
stand against unruly mobs that are
destroying public and private property
and then an a president who is for law
and order but also justice and fairness
and restoring peace and prosperity the
decline was severe during the
coronavirus worst moments in March and
April but are in the biggest parts of
the shutdown millions and millions of
jobs were lost and obviously the economy
took a big hit
the president has even said that they
may have to have some more economic
stimulus so we're not out of the woods
yet economically and and obviously how
things are in the fault we don't know
yet so what will the president be saying
to contrast the arguments that he was in
charge when things went bad in March and
April
certainly unprecedented to have the
greatest economy in generations
completely just shut down hey I mean
it's completely unprecedented you've
never said hey don't go to work and it's
all because of the pandemic from
Communist China that regime hid this
virus from the world and the entire
world not just the country has faced the
brunt of that those decisions made of
the Chinese Communist Party but what the
Democrats in the media are discounting
is the resilience of the American people
and the strength and the fundamentals of
that economy that are so strong going
into this it's a completely different
environment back in 2008 and 2009 before
the president left for Arizona he talked
to reporters outside the White House
discussing Saturday's rally we had a
night
though there were reports he was angry
the arena had empty seats the president
was asked about what he said that night
that he had asked to slow down testing
as the corona virus surges in many
states his campaign and White House
press secretary later said that was in
jest an attempt at humor but he called
it a double-edged sword
in one way it tells you you have cases
in another way you find out where the
cases are and you do a good job eight of
the cases where Trump campaign staffers
who got the virus in Oklahoma amid
criticism people were too close than
many weren't masked when the protests
came over the George Floyd killing and
when those were hijacked by radical
elements and descended into riots where
was the government where was the lecture
about social distancing where where were
the public health concerns and they
weren't there so so much of this
unfortunately from the Democrat side has
been political president Trump has been
interested in delivering for the
American people what's best for us and
people do want to get out there I think
you've seen a lot of Republican
governors giving their citizens the
flexibility and the respect they deserve
to make these decisions for themselves
we've learned a lot about this virus
we've learned things that can protect
the most vulnerable that's what we
always should have focused on in
Oklahoma and Arizona these two states
that the president's been to in the last
couple of days there has been record
numbers of coronavirus cases and in
Arizona a record number of
hospitalizations would you and would the
Trump campaign be wanting more social
distancing at rallies wanting more
people to wear masks in Tulsa they had
hand sanitizer did do temperature check
to try to limit anyone that was
symptomatic going into the facility and
they handed out masks for anyone to wear
as they see fit we think that trust in
the American people so important and
what Americans really make these
decisions and that's still within the
guidance so we think as more and more
states are becoming fully open people
have learned a lot how to do that safely
President Trump his trail did a lot of
different polls whether they're national
or some of the battleground states the
Trump campaign and the president
continue to say the polls are wrong or
and they're broken what is it about
polling we've this dates back to 2016
what is it about polling that
Republicans think is going wrong
I see the methodology and all of these
mainstream polls the vast majority are
just wrong and was this the same thing
that you did in 2016 that showed Hillary
Clinton up by 12 points or 10 points
they're not finding people that are
actually likely voters and they're
almost always oversampling Democrats a
recent Reuters poll pulled 10 percent
more Democrats than Republicans so when
you're asking 10 and 110 regrets and
Republicans you're probably going to see
10% bigger gap that's not what the
electorate is going to look like on
November 3rd we thank Liz Harrington
from the Republican National Committee
and shift gears to Joe Biden
who held a virtual fundraiser Tuesday
with his old boss for the first time for
President Obama after the ex-vice
president put out a statement very
critical of president Trump's trip to
Arizona calling the wall expensive and
ineffective adding it was reckless and
irresponsible for the president to hold
a rally in Phoenix Biden says his Korona
response is a failure and the attempt at
recovery corrupt Robert wolf is a former
Obama economic adviser now a Fox News
contributor I'm one of those who's
rooting for the economy I'm not one of
those that wants us to go into a
recession and have more people
unemployed because that's politically
favorable to Joe Biden I'm not that way
I ran a bank
okay so I've always been a capitalist my
opinion is very clearly we are in a
recession I don't think the recovery has
been the v-shape
this administration's been talking about
it's too early to tell I was very clear
on Fox that President Trump and his
advisor spiking the football is an is
incredibly premature we still have over
20 million more unemployed people since
a pandemic begun we need to figure out
how to come together to do what cares
that four-point-oh we need to keep small
businesses vibrant now spending clearly
is important it's a big part of economic
growth if you have a lot of people out
of work the spending I know we had to
jump up in May do you see that as
sustainable June and July do you think
that is possible to keep it going where
we have big rises back up yes the retail
sales number was good but it's off an
incredibly low base but also what was
interesting is a larger proportion of
the middle and lower class spent more
money and middle and upper class spent
less money versus the norm on retail
sales so definitely tells you that these
benefits from the cares Act were helpful
we should look at things like rebates so
when people spend money maybe they get a
tax rebate so we actually do something
what I would say more on the demand side
of the consumer
you mentioned small businesses they a
lot of them got loans but that money is
going to run out and if we have
restaurants only allowed to be half full
and you don't have as many people go
into gyms and salons and all those kinds
of things do we need to give them more
money yeah I mean I've been clear all on
Dave I thought that the payroll
protection program was way too small we
only gave to about 12% of small
businesses and so we know that we didn't
literally give too near enough
historically it's not easy for a
president to be re-elected in a bad
economy if you're the Biden campaign is
that still what you hammer at the most I
think there's a few things one I think
independent boat is if you look at
recent Fox polls you know they're
looking for to come back to some sort of
normalcy I think people are
getting exhausted by waking up and going
to sleep to to the Twitter present I
just think it's exhausting so one I do
think that Biden is doing better with
independence and moderates a lot of it
will be on who's better to take us into
a recovery and I think that the
president trickle-down economics really
didn't work well he is all he has said
that the economy was roaring like it
never had been before and tell them the
the coronavirus took it down obviously
you don't see it that way
well that's just not factual because
we've had GDP much greater than 3% many
many times in many many years right I
think GDP under this president has been
under two and a half percent so one
those numbers aren't accurate number two
with respect to wages wages have gone up
not even where inflation has been number
three if you look at yes the
unemployment rate was great don't get me
wrong and I'm glad it was great but if
you look at jobs numbers President
Obama's last two years were better than
President Trump's first two yeah the
first two years on jobs there have been
some that have feared that the the Biden
campaign will be hijacked by the too far
left of the party and turn off maybe
independent voters do you see that as
possible or not well there's no question
that our party overall has shifted left
Joe Biden's not a socialist at all
I believe the Democratic Party is a
pro-business party I think we just look
at business that should be actually fear
to all and we shouldn't have the income
inequality and wealth inequality we have
today Robert wolf we really thank you
very much for your time today thanks for
joining us thanks for having me on Dave
[Music]
this is Abbi hornacek with your Fox News
commentary
coming up it's beginning to sound a
little like March states pleading with
residents to help stop the spread of
coronavirus Koba 19 is now spreading at
an unacceptable rate in Texas and it
must be corralled governor Greg Abbott
urging people to social distance wear
masks and even stay home as the state
tops 5,000 new cases of the virus in a
single day he had been one of the
Republican governors who seemed to side
with the president's argument about
ramped up testing but White House Task
Force member dr. Anthony foul she told a
House hearing Tuesday the rising numbers
of cases are troublesome you are now
seeing a disturbing surge of infections
that looks like it's a combination but
one of the things is an increase in
community spread he also remains
cautiously optimistic about the chance
for a vaccine by early next year or even
late this year but for now a recent
surge continues in more than 20 states I
am concerned about the surge but my
concern is different depending upon the
state and on the local dynamics dr. Amos
Adal juh is an infectious disease
physician at a senior scholar at the
Johns Hopkins University Center for
health security we do know that as
people interact it's inevitable that
you're going to see more cases the
question always becomes are those cases
manageable in places where the percent
positivity of tests that are returning
positive is increasing that's where I'm
more worried and I'm also worried about
places where hospital capacity seems to
be under stress like for example we
heard in Arizona and Montgomery Alabama
that's those are the markers I look at
so it's not Universal across the country
as we see new cases but in those certain
places that are becoming new hot spots
where we're worried about kind of
spiraling a little bit out of control
that's our my concern lies I know with
that what you mentioned about the
positivity raid is very important
because some officials including the
president
keep trying to make the argument that
case is arising because the u.s. is
doing so much testing I mean is there
any truth to that no we are doing more
testing but the number of positive cases
is rising faster than our rise in
testing so that tells you that there is
transmission going on and if you look
even as a nation at the percent
positivity it had been below 5% for some
time and is now going above 5% even as
testing you know as testing goes up it
shouldn't be going up in that at that
level you you would expect it to still
stay low if there was an increased
transmission and when you look at some
of the places for example that we're
really concerned about like Arizona the
percent positivity of tests went from
below 10% to around 20% now that's
that's concerning that tells you that
there are chains of transmission that
are ongoing that are not being managed
by case contact investigation that they
might be unrecognized chains of
transmission and what we worry about is
those chains spilling into hospitals and
putting them under stress and indeed
we're hearing about that in Arizona that
there is stress on their hospitals and
this really argues that we need to get
aggressive with our case can contact
finding in those places where test
positivity is going up do we have a
sense of what is driving this increase
right now is is the timing because of
the wave of states that eased
restrictions around Memorial Day it
really has to do with a lot of things
but that is part of it I think it's
important to remember that when we had
enforced social distancing by the states
that was really to preserve hospital
capacity it wasn't about the virus going
away and when those lifted it didn't
mean that the virus was gone
the virus was going to be with us and
every every one of our activities until
there is a vaccine and I think that's
something that's lost on people that
when you go out and do things when you
interact with people there is going to
be a nonzero risk of transmission and as
we see people doing that you're going to
see more cases hopefully the cases can
be kept to a level that our case contact
investigators can deal with them so that
they don't set off chains of
transmission that end up putting us into
problems in hospitals but that's not
always going to be the case if we don't
have properly resourced health
department so I do think that
there's a lot of things going on going
on at once right now
there there is some more testing going
on for example in jails and and in
meatpacking plants but that's not the
whole picture it really has to do with
people socially interacting and that's
why you're seeing this skewing and the
data with younger individuals getting
diagnosed now because those are the
first people who are venturing out now
because they're less risk-averse than
older populations you might have
pre-existing conditions so it's all
fitting with more social interaction
more mobility causing more cases to to
spread and and I think that's going to
be the new normal and it really speaks
to the fact that we need to get control
of these cases through aggressive case
management yeah and I guess people
should also not take this as a sign that
masks and social distancing don't work
right instead it's it's because people
aren't doing them enough exactly I think
this is it something that people have to
learn to live with they have to adjust
to to being in environments where this
virus is always going to be a risk
either a risk that you're gonna transmit
it or a risk that you're going to
acquire it and you still need to be
mindful of social distancing washing
your hands frequently not touching your
face face coverings as needed
all of that's going to be part of how we
move forward with this with this
pandemic virus until there is a vaccine
and I think what happens is that out of
sight kind of out of mind when people
see that green fur for restaurants and
bars opening they forget that there is
still going to be a risk there that is
that is sizeable and we want to make
sure that we don't put our hospitals
into crisis so people still need to be
responsible people really need to think
about their contacts and think about
what's essential to them what's not
essential to them and try and practice
the best social distancing they can even
if they want to go to a restaurant or a
bar
Florida's another one of the surge
states one of only seven nationwide to
top 100,000 cases and packed bars are
getting some of the blame what we've
seen particularly over the last week as
a real explosion in new cases amongst
our younger demographics governor
Rhonda's Santas says bars and
restaurants that don't follow limits on
capacity will face a temporary shutdown
the mayor of Miami is
making masks mandatory a steps of other
cities and states have taken and
Louisiana's governor is among those
tapping the brakes on the next phase of
reopening this makes talk of a
fast-track vaccine all the more
tantalizing but how realistic is that I
think it's always been overly optimistic
it's in the realm of possibility but it
would be really record-breaking to have
a vaccine develop that quickly vaccine
development is something we usually
measure in years
not in - although we're taking really
breathtaking steps to get a vaccine
developed quicker we're already in phase
3 clinical trials which is unheard of
using new technologies that didn't exist
even 10 years ago I do think it is it's
something that we don't want to wet
ourselves - we don't want to say that
we're gonna have a vaccine by a certain
date and then miss that deadline because
invariably there's going to be hiccups
in production when you're trying to make
vaccine to do the whole US population or
the whole world population so I do think
we have paired two to face this virus
without a vaccine I think we will have a
vaccine there's no biological barrier to
having a vaccine we have animal
coronavirus vaccines that are that are
highly successful in the veterinary
world it's just a question of can we get
the data necessary to say that this is a
safe and effective vaccine in the
fastest possible time period they think
that's a that's always going to be a
concern when you're doing something on
such a grand scale and hopefully we we
do get to that we do get batches of the
vaccine by the end of the year but I
don't think that it's something that I
would that I would completely guarantee
will happen well where does that leave
us then for something like the start of
the school year this fall I mean some
districts are definitely planning at
this point to at least try to open but
you know what would it take for you to
be telling them no you shouldn't or
would you already be saying that schools
are they were closed basically
reflexively because of extrapolations
from influenza and we're finding that
this virus behaves very differently than
influenza in influenza children are
major magnifiers of infection and we're
not seeing that so much with this virus
we're not hearing about epidemics that
are being started or outbreaks being
started or driven by children we know
that there have been schools already
open in the United States and places
like Montana and Idaho and they seem to
be operating okay we know some countries
did
close schools and we also know that
daycare centers for essential workers
were open throughout this pandemic and
we haven't heard about outbreaks there
so I think that when it comes to opening
schools because children are relatively
spared from the epidemiology of this
meaning they don't transmit it today
they don't seem to be driving outbreaks
and they seem to be spared from severe
cases I do think this is something
that's one of the first things that
probably can open and I do think we will
see schools being open being open I
think this should be a separate decision
regarding other things because children
have such a unique role here obviously
we have to protect the vulnerable
populations that might be in schools
like teachers or ancillary personnel
that might be in high-risk groups but I
do think that we can probably have
schools in a modified fashion because
you have to remember that there are
major societal costs to having schools
closed many children get their meals
from schools many many children
especially as stay at home owners are
lifted are gonna congregate outside of
schools and kind of defeat the purpose
of it and you have to remember that most
of this distance learning that's gone on
has not been very successful if you look
at the nation as a whole it's been very
difficult for students to actually learn
I think there are real psychosocial
costs to the system that we're doing
right now which is really magnifying
differences between school districts and
resources between school districts so so
I do think that schools are a separate
decision and I think based on all the
data we have now on children in their
role in this infection I do think it's
likely something that can be done safely
and should be done do you think doctor
that people are concerned enough about
this virus and I asked because some
people are so willing to sit in a
restaurant or a bar or on a plane for
that matter and others won't even
consider those things until there's a
vaccine are weak are we worried enough
are we concerned enough so I do think
that there's different ways that people
can try and incorporate this new virus
into their everyday risk calculation and
I think it's going to be different for
each person because each person as we
know from every activity in life has a
different risk tolerance and some people
are very risk-averse and some people are
very risk tolerant and there aren't
susceptibilities to severe disease we
know that this virus doesn't hit people
equally and that there are people that
vulnerable that are older that have
other medical conditions that are more
likely to be hospitalized and have a
severe case and there are other people
who may not have any symptoms at all and
I think that's kind of conditioning how
people think about this virus but from a
public health or an infectious disease
physician standpoint I do think we we
cannot emphasize enough that this is
still going to be a major challenge from
an infectious disease standpoint and we
are going to see more cases more
hospitalizations and more deaths until
there is a vaccine and we can't behave
as if the virus isn't out there it
doesn't mean that we have to go to a
luhan style lockdown but it means that
people have to try to find a balance a
way to reduce the harm from this virus
by taking common-sense precautions to
try and prevent yourself from getting
infected or spreading this or becoming
part of a chain of transmission and I
think we can do it safely but people
have to realize that they cannot behave
as if the virus is not there and not
expect to suffer the consequences of
that dr. Anna shaddoll Jeff from Johns
Hopkins thank you so much for your time
sure thank you for having me
download and make it hammer time with
Bill Hemmer
trey gowdy welcome so if the Department
is going to start issuing making public
investigations about people that you
don't even have enough information to
charge that is a slippery slope
subscribe and listen now by going to Fox
News podcasts com subscribe to this
podcast at Fox News podcasts dot-com
it's time for your fox news commentary
what's on your mind
the census is that thing that you get in
the mailbox every 10 years that you
think you probably should fill out but
then it slips your mind and then you get
busy than two months later you find it
stuffed in your drawer it is so easy to
let the census come and go without
filling in your data but after my chat
with the folks over at the US Census
Bureau for my podcast getting schooled I
learned some things that definitely
encouraged me to get mine in the mailbox
so I thought I share look this is my
first year filling in the census ten
years ago I was 16 years old so my mom
definitely helped me out with that one
but as I've gotten older I think there's
a common fear about giving away your
information to the government so I can
understand that in a world of heightened
transparency why people might be a
little weary of giving away their
personal information but something I
learned from Virginia hire who is the
spokeswoman over at the Census Bureau
was all employees of the Census Bureau
actually taken oath for life to promise
to keep any personal information or data
they collect private plus the reality is
the census has changed a lot since
Thomas Jefferson instituted it back in
1790 during the Great Depression the
Census Bureau asked a lot of questions
about a given households financial
status due to the wide spread property
at the time but now as you've seen if
you've filled out a census the questions
are geared towards a wide variety of
topics the reality is you're not just
helping the government you're helping
yourself and your community by filling
it out everyday citizens can use the
census to enhance their
own understanding of their communities
for example let's say you were
interested in let's say opening a bike
shop right you could look at the data
the US Census Bureau has on how many
people bike to work in your area that
way you could find out where the highest
density for need is and then maximize
your opportunity and profit also the
constitutional basis for conducting the
decennial census is to reapportioned the
House of Representatives so by filling
out your census you're actually helping
decide how many of the 435 seats in the
house your state gets and just to be
clear here I do not work for the Census
and I have no skin in the game of
whether or not you fill out your census
but if you're looking to improve your
community and get the right amount of
representation in the House of
Representatives you might want to go
back into that drawer and dig out your
census and get it in the mail Plus who
doesn't love some data i'ma be warned a
sec
you've been listening to the box news
rundown and stay up to date by
subscribing to this podcast at FoxNews
podcasts calm and for up-to-the-minute
news go to Fox news.com
[Music]
love FoxNews click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust and click the FoxNews rundown
playlist for the latest episodes